galoper sur la plage de sainte marie
c'est tenir compte de nombreux facteurs
les trous les courbes les vagues
c'est aussi un plaisir en vous tampon
beau ces jeunes ont donc une passion
depuis la maternelle
le cheval formés en alternance à l'école
des courses hippiques à paris ou à
mont-de-marsan
l'afa sec jockey driver aux cavaliers
l'atb rêveur c'était très difficile le
début je voulais rentrer chez moi mais
après je me suis dit bon allez on va
continuer on va aller jusqu'au bout et
puis ça allait tout seul après il faut
se battre
bien sûr ça il faut se font toujours se
battre pour sa place après 50 ans papa
du matin
fait les boks donne une ration de manger
au chaud un repas chaud et après on fait
le pansage tout ça en selle je suis à
cheval pendant
d'ailleurs quatre 4 5 heures pour cette
séance d'entraînement avant le pause de
15 août on découvre le terrain la plage
de sainte marie change régulièrement de
visage c'est vraiment pas facile parce
que on a le sable il s'agit le savent
j'ai pas trouvé gillan et 1 donc il faut
vraiment être le au bon on doit pouvoir
galoper
alors ça c'est à dire aussi question de
passion d'abord il commence par faire
des balades intrus et puis mon ca
d'autres salles vient de petit à petit
on a réservé une course uniquement pour
cinq cavaliers de l'école de la face et
puis ça fait quelques années qu'on
milite avec les jeunes pour qu'on puisse
leur donner notre passion et les faire
découvrir le monde hippique huit courses
sont prévues cette année
chevaux mulet et poneys également